Donald Trump has unfortunately for Americans,
once again, completely embarrassed himself,
extension,
embarrass the United States on the world stage
at yesterday speech that he gave in front
of the United nations general assembly. Now
as a speech, it was horrendous, extremely
low energy. It was that mumbling stumbling
Trump that often appears to be coming down
from uppers. As I've mentioned before, that
showed up to yesterday speech. Now, hilariously,
there were actually some journalistic descriptions
of the speech that called it sober and respectful,
which are the most polite possible words that
you can assign to downer Trump, the version
of Trump that shows up when he is in that
coming down from uppers sort of mode that
we've identified before. Now of course, Donald
Trump used the teleprompter, which also helps
to keep Trump in that low energy mode something.
Remember, he made fun of Barack Obama for
using when Barack Obama was president. It
turns out, I guess that using a teleprompter
and being able to read leads to far better
speeches than using a teleprompter and struggling
to read, which is what Donald Trump does every
single time he uses that prompter.
But it wasn't just the style of Trump's speech
that was atrocious. The content of the speech
was disgusting as well. This was one of the
most nationalists speeches that Donald Trump
has given, criticizing countries that in his
view treat the U S unfairly talking about
being against globalism and for patriotism,
which is once again this tired, antisemitic
trope, throwing in some awkwardly worded deference
to things like treating people well and valuing
differences, which we have no evidence that
actually suggests Trump believes or even thinks
is important. Uh, and uh, once again downer.
Trump is the guy that showed up. This is the
one that appears to be coming down from uppers
slurring, doing the [inaudible] thing when
S's exist in words appearing to chew on his
own teeth, stopping looking confused at the
words on the teleprompter. Take a look.
The world fully expects that the Chinese government
will honor its binding treaty. It is time
for Ron's leaders to step forward. America
is ready to embrace friendship with all who
genuinely seek peace. The receiving countries
are overburdened with more migrants and they
can responsibly accept nations that empower
women are much wealthier, safer, and much
more prominently stable. Americans will never
fire or tire in our effort to defend and promote
freedom. Liberty is only preserved. Sovereign
is only secured. Yesterday I was also pleased
to host leaders for a discussion about an
iron Clare American commitment.
Extraordinarily strange behavior. I mean just
again, genuinely strange behavior that I've
heard reasonable explanation for so far. Let's
look at another moment from the speech here
were Donald Trump does his globalism, bad
patriotism, good thing
the free world must embrace its national foundations.
It must not attempt to erase them or replace
them looking around and all over his large,
magnificent planet. The truth is playing to
see if you want freedom, take pride in your
country. If you want democracy, hold onto
your sovereignty and if you want peace, love
your nation. Wise leaders always put the good
of their own people and their own country
first. The future does not belong to globalists.
The future belongs to Patriots. The future
belongs to sovereign and independent nation
who protect their citizens, respect their
neighbors and honor the differences that make
each country special and unique. It is why
we in the United States have the barked on
an exciting program of national renewal.
We're not globalists, but we are Patriots
now, as I mentioned already, extremely low
energy, so energy, a solo energy. In fact
that one of Donald Trump's cabinet secretaries
slept through the speech. We'll talk about
that a little bit later, but more importantly,
looking awful, sounding awful and the content
being ridiculous. The entire criticizing globalists
thing has an ugly antisemitic past. Whether
or not Donald Trump knows that, whether or
not Donald Trump is deliberately referencing
it for that reason, but it's a dog whistle
for Jews that has been around for a very,
very, very long time. But it's important not
to miss the bigger picture here, which is
that the United States is increasingly not
part of the serious and important conversations
that world leaders around the world are having.
Trying to solve some of the big problems of
our time. The big picture is that Donald Trump's
reference to an antisemitic trope shouldn't
be allowed to distract us from an increasingly
cornered and backpedaling Donald Trump on
his excuses for why he would withhold the
hundreds of million dollars in aid from Ukraine
because he wanted them to smear Joe Biden
while suppressing a whistleblower.
And in the end it becomes difficult to even
figure out which ridiculous public embarrassment
or crisis is meant to be a distraction from
some other, sometimes even worse, ridiculous
public embarrassment, but embarrassing himself
on the world stage is something that has become
unfortunately all too common under this presidency.
I know that the Trump has don't agree with
me and I know that they also don't care what
other countries think about Trump. And in
fact that they become emboldened when they
hear that other countries are not even including
Trump and conversations about climate change
for, for example, other countries are not
even including Trump in conversations about
how can we get Iran back into compliance with
the Iran nuclear deal. Particularly given
that Trump bailed on the deal without Iran
having actually broken any of the conditions
of that deal. And when we look at the coverage
of something like the UN general assembly
here in the United States, we understandably
have a very Trump centric view.
Either people who love what Trump did or anybody
who has a good head on their shoulders and
realizes the embarrassing nature of what Trump
did in other countries. It's not just that
they are much more unanimous in their understanding
that what Trump said is ridiculous. It's arguably
even worse where it doesn't even really matter
what Donald Trump is doing and saying because
other countries are increasingly not even
including the United States in important conversations
about so many of the issues that are facing
humanity right now, and that's the real tragedy
that it will take a long time to undo once
Donald Trump is no longer president.